[Music]
there's nothing worse than being hungry
and if I need someone has messed with
your food from paying for all of that
air that comes in a bag of chips to
finding an egg without an actual yolk
sometimes people just get terribly
unlucky stay until the end to see the
most unfortunate avocado ever don't
forget to hit the thumbs up button and
subscribe to our Channel today we're
checking out ten people who absolutely
lost the food lottery watermelon let's
start with a simple fruit do you love
watermelon we can't blame you it's juicy
delicious and a perfect fruit for the
summer it's hard to believe that
purchasing a watermelon could go wrong
but this person has the worst luck when
it comes to fruit depending on where
you're from watermelon can be quite
expensive so imagine spending all that
money and carrying a home a heavy
watermelon only to find this on the
inside it looks like the flesh of this
watermelon didn't manage to grow into
the side of its shelf don't know about
you but we're pretty sure we'd lose our
minds if this happened to us watermelon
is made of mostly water but this
watermelon looks like it's on a whole
nother level speaking of delicious fruit
did you know that the red pigment inside
fruit actually has a very high amount of
Lysa bean nutrient which is responsible
for making you stronger and healthier if
you're not stocking up on watermelon yet
no it's time to start just make sure you
don't end up with this unfortunate
watermelon there's actually no foolproof
way of knowing a watermelon is ripe but
you should always tap on them to see if
they're hollow the better the sound the
better the watermelon so next time
you're in a supermarket you have the
watermelon a tap or two to find out
which one will be the tastiest we hope
you don't end up with a watermelon that
looks like this
bread and if you thought the unlucky
watermelon was bad wait until you see
this unfortunate food staple our Channel
totally loves bread and we can't imagine
not having our morning avocado toast
almost everyone enjoys eating bread and
if you don't you're missing out on all
the yummy carbohydrates that gives you
energy this bread is delicious and
there's no possible way for you to end
up purchasing bread that's completely
inedible well that's true but what would
you do if you go into the bakery buy a
freshly made loaf and it ends up looking
like this the loaf is made of air and
that hole is pretty much occupying half
of it how did this person not see that
their red looks
like this in the first place and how
come the store didn't notice the loaf
was actually missing more than half of
the bread speaking of bread you know
that countries like the UK waste one in
every three slices of bread about 32% of
sold bread goes into the trash so
perhaps this is just an actual
representation of how much loaf we'd
actually eat nevertheless we can imagine
most of us would be pretty upset if this
happened to us we're calling this loaf
the err bread bread slice the wrong way
you thought our bread was bad well it is
but this is just kind of funny buying
already sliced bread is perfect for
those who aren't good at cutting bread
in different sizes guilty as charged
but in this person's case it looks like
the bread cutting machine had an off day
and ended up slicing the bread
horizontally instead of vertically this
doesn't seem like a bad option you just
end up with long toast sandwiches if you
absolutely had to choose which of these
bread mishaps would you pick the
horizontally sliced bread or the
half-full bread err loaf considering
this second bread looks like it's been
store-bought we can imagine there are a
few more unfortunate customers that
manage to purchase this item we'd make
the most of it and create a four layer
sandwich subway style or just cut the
slices in half and it'll look like
nothing happened did you know that a
traditional loaf can be made just using
four ingredients all you need to make
bread is flour yeast water and salt next
time you're in the supermarket check out
the ingredients on your package project
and see what else you can find if you
can't pronounce it it probably doesn't
need to be there no yoke
how do comedians like their eggs funny
side up okay okay that was one cheesy
yolk unless you're a bodybuilder there's
a good chance that eating egg whites
only are not the most appealing thing
ever we can't blame you because
everyone's in it for that runny eggs
yolk that you dip your bread in on a
Sunday brunch well that is if you
actually end up getting yolk in your egg
this unlucky person didn't and he was
just as surprised as we are but maybe
it's a good thing this egg didn't have a
yolk do you know that there's an ongoing
debate over the nutritional value of
eggs they're a fantastic source of
protein but egg whites are considerably
healthier than yolks it's not all that
bad though and egg yolk is one of the
only foods out there that's naturally
containing vitamin D eggs are also
really sued
for your voice because of their high
amount of vitamin A but we can't even
begin to explain what happened to this
poor egg and how it managed to lose its
yolk we do have one question which came
first the chicken or the egg without the
yolk no cone ice cream cone we hope
you're ready for this next one because
it's quite upsetting imagine it being a
hot summer day and you want some ice
cream you buy one of those Cornetto
types in the store and excitedly open
the box you take one out and unwrap it
only to find that this ice cream has no
actual cone how could this ever happen
if you lived in a hot climate your ice
cream would melt in no time talking
about absolutely losing the food lottery
this person probably had the weirdest
experience of everyone on our list then
again all you need to do in this case is
transfer this ice cream into a bowl and
voila it's a perfect option for those
who absolutely love ice cream but hate
that comes the chocolate swirls on this
ice cream actually looked pretty cool
this mishap is still not as bad as
dropping your entire ice cream cone on
the floor seconds after buying it either
way we feel for this person and we hope
they found this just as amusing as we do
do you know that a sundae can actually
have as much fat and calories as a
regular t-bone steak dinner we can't
blame you for eating ice cream though
it's so delicious cranberry chocolate no
one likes false advertising especially
when it comes to food we all like to eat
exactly what we're shown in those
commercials and on the packages but
sometimes it just doesn't happen we feel
for this person who purchased cranberry
chocolate only to find that the bar only
comes with six cranberries and from what
it looks like it was the sixth hour on
the preview display of the chocolate bar
the Polish company behind this chocolate
has actually been slammed online for
false advertising luckily we didn't
manage to find any other similar mishaps
with the same brand what would you do if
this happened to you would you take the
product back to the store and request a
refund would you post it online to raise
awareness or just let it go nobody
should mess with chocolate and we can
imagine why so many people are totally
outraged with this photo
however mistakes like that can happen
this chocolate also doesn't look like it
has a lot of hazelnuts and it's not just
chocolate this also happens with other
food check out this very unfortunate
blueberry waffle that seems to only have
us see
blueberry we can't imagine what's worse
messing up so much chocolate or messing
up their breakfast a can of water we all
know that canned food could actually be
a letdown on its own the food doesn't
often come the way it looks on the
packaging and sometimes it just tastes
way off but at least you're not this
person's mother we're not sure what
happened here but it just seems too
bizarre to be true the caption of this
picture reads my mom opened a can of
black beans but there was only water
inside and it's probably one of the most
disappointing things we've ever seen we
can't even begin to explain how this
could have happened in the first place
was the cam so old it made the beans in
Fabray or was this the actual can
without any beans just water
whatever the reason we're pretty sure
you wouldn't be happy if he started
making dinner only to find that the can
of beans actually looks like this since
canned water is actually a thing could
this just be a canned water in disguise
we'll probably never know the real
answer we just feel bad for that mom and
hope she had an extra can of black beans
as a backup can't even imagine the
disappointment on her face but she
noticed there was absolutely no beans
inside this unfortunate cam this time
just look at that cute little lemon
small things are normally cute and if
you're a fan of eating healthy you
normally do a lot of portion control on
your plate but what can you possibly do
with something like this this Internet
users started growing a lemon tree and
it seemed to have produced these teeny
tiny lemon sure they look cute what are
you supposed to do with this
we hope their tree managed to produce
some decent sized lemons as well having
a lemon tree is actually a really good
idea did you know that lemons have
several nutritional vitamins that can
help boost your immune system there are
also several ways you can use a lemon to
clean your entire house it's definitely
a versatile fruit and a lemon tree can
actually survive indoors if it's getting
enough direct sunlight
either way this tiny lemon definitely
looks cute too and while this person
might have lost the food lottery they
won a ridiculously cute miniature fruit
competition if you're looking to add
more lemon to your life we recommend
drinking lemon water let the lemon sit
in the water for a couple of hours and
overnight and then drink it every
morning health benefits of this drink
include skin improvements and digestion
aids weep that this tiny lemon could
still be
put to good use this sub most of us
probably love sandwiches and it's our
go-to meal at work or on a busy day at
home what do you think Joey Tribbiani
would do if he ended up getting a
sandwich looking like this
this looks like just a regular sub it
actually looks amazing from an aerial
point of view that is until you bite
into it and realize there's hardly any
cheese or salami in it we're not sure
where this person got the sandwich from
but we hope they took it back and had a
little word because that's definitely
not what a sandwich should look like did
you know that 50% of American population
eats a sandwich every day we can't blame
them they're easy and quick to make and
they're absolutely delicious well that
is if you actually end up getting the
ingredients you're supposed to get in
the sandwich we really feel for this
person and they really are one of those
people that totally lost the food
lottery we can probably handle a loaf
half filled with air or a horizontally
sliced piece of bread put a sandwich
looking like this you can't even imagine
how it happened in the first place well
it's still not as bad as the last person
our list we really do feel for this user
poor avocado people have a love/hate
relationship with avocados over the past
few years the public got absolutely
hooked on avocados from toasts and
stuffed avocados to substituting them
for sour cream and other ingredients
this fruit has been taking over the
world and yes it's been declared that an
avocado is technically a fruit if you're
a frequent avocado eater you know that
you need to have good luck if you want
to find one that's perfectly ripe leave
it alone for too long and you'll end up
wasting a lot of money for a fruit that
seems to be good for only a couple of
days everyone knows a becan o's are
expensive but imagine buying the fruit
and ending up with something that looks
like this it looks like the Pitt took
over this massive avocado and made it
completely inedible we don't know who we
feel more terrible for this avocado or
the person who bought it what would you
do if this happened to you
the internet claims that those avocado
pits are actually really healthy for you
but these claims have yet to be
supported by researchers what you can do
is ko your avocado houses limit and then
freeze them to make them last longer if
you ended up with a hard avocado you
could also bake it in the oven for a few
minutes to make it ripe
we're crazy about avocado don't forget
to click that like button and subscribe
to our channel for more videos like this
one make sure to check
ten hotels that filled so badly it's
funny see you there
[Music]